à isabelle balkany et août et les padres
oui bonsoir isabelle ah non oui bonsoir
isabelle ça va bien isabelle bonsoir
cyril matin va bien oui madame à
beaucoup mieux
bon ça va mieux jojo jean todt à votre
voix je sens que ça va mieux ah oui
l'euphorique c'est vrai bon écoutez en
tout cas on a vu les images et que l'on
soit pour ou contre comme je l'aï dit
autour de cette table
c'est vrai que vous voir voilà les deux
comme ça voilà amoureux comme ça mine de
rien nous on pense pas la politique on
pense et on s'est dit voilà mine de rien
c'est ici c'est magnifique je sais pas
ce que va réaliser autour de la table et
je crois que l'acte de grandes choses
dans la vie mois isabelle moi ce que
j'ai ce que j'avais à vous dire ce soir
parce que je sais que vous êtes beaucoup
battu pour patrick et c'est vrai que
c'est ce qu'on disait ici on disait il
ya plein d'autres détenus aussi qu'ils
sont malades qui sont en prison car s et
c'est vrai que eux aussi je pense que
s'il faut essayer de les faire sortir et
un rat vous bien ça fait partie de les
savez moi je suis une femme de combat
j'ai toujours des combats toujours un
combat devant moi et là c'en est un
parce que allah après tout dépend aussi
ce qui était un peu extraordinaire dans
le cas de patrick c'était à la fois de
son âge et en raison de son
incarcération qui sont uniques
on n'a jamais vu donc après tout dépend
de ce qui s'est passé avant mais c'est
vrai quoi oui je vois ce que voulait
dire en tout cas vous allez aujourd'hui
même droit ça reste être un nouveau
combat parce que c'est vrai que nous on
est très regardée sachez le il avait
dans les prisons
il ya plein de gens qui nous regardent
dont un petit peu le sucre et d'oxygène
le soir et on leur fait peur
coucou d'ailleurs et voilà ils nombreux
mandats dit tout à l'heure et je sais
qu'il y en a qui souffrent de
pathologies graves
jmm incurable et je crois que vous savez
la présidente du tribunal de la cour
d'appel avait dit dans une interview que
la justice était faite par des hommes et
des femmes parce qu'elles devaient être
humaine et je trouve que voilà et le
fondement de la justice et battre
isabelle en tout cas merci d'avoir été
avec nous ce soir
j'espère que vous avez passé voilà une
autre est-ce que vous faire un gros bill
ou virtuels balesi a pas de problème
poisson avec un avec plaisir à vous je
vous embrasse tous les deux et vous
allez me soutenir si je me présente on
en 2022 alors complètement figurez vous
qu'on vient de m'apprendre sa batterie
complètement
on va très bien ça me fait plaisir alors
j'avais trouvé la candidature de coluche
et trois mineurs eh ben je vous fais de
gros bisous et donc ce que vous leur
héritier mâle si vous avez du nid et
besoin vieille qui sait ce que c'est
qu'une campagne électorale puis là bas
j'ai déjà benhaim mais merci frère